make you think we're already it's nearly
ready yes it keeps these are called
Lukas Carmichael members so they named
after two very famous mathematicians
Edward Lukas and Robert Daniel
Carmichael so if you have a composite
number which we'll call n and so it's
got some prime factors so we have a
composite integer number that's not
prime it's not prime right because it's
made up of prime numbers is made up of
prime factors then what makes it a Lukas
Carmichael number is P plus 1
is a factor of n plus one shall I give
you an example yes the smallest value n
can have actually is 399 so it gives you
a flavor that these are not everyday
numbers right they're not this 298 I've
gone before them without their this been
satisfied so what is what are the prime
factors of 399 well it's 3 times 7 times
19 so what do I do I now add 1 because
400 and 400 has factors of 4 which is 3
plus 1/8 which is 7 plus 1 and 20 we
know that 20 goes into 400 we know that
8 goes into 400 goes 50 times and we
know that 4 goes into 400 they're not
the only factors and they're not prime
factors of course they are just the
factors but the key thing the the neat
thing is that I've added 1 to the number
and it turns out that by that all the
the original prime factors if I just add
1 to them they are also a factors of my
new number that's one example let's do
another one so 935 for example that has
prime factors which are 5 times 11 times
17 and if I add 1 I got 936 and the
factors of 936 include 5 plus 1 xi plus
1 which is 12 and 17 plus 1 which is 18
you can play around with them as much as
you like but they're not that easy to
find so 2015 and if I add 1 in 2016 so
this is this has got 4 digits so and
that these have got 3 factors and the
smallest lucas carmichael number with 5
factors is in fact 5 8 8 4 5 5 and
that's made up of 5 times 7 times 17
23 times 43 and so forth if I add one
then it has factors 5 plus 1 is 6 7 plus
1 is 8 17 plus 1 is 18 23 plus 1 is 24
and 43 plus 1 is 44 I don't think a
great deal is known about them that they
they're there they're out there and
they're not that common I think I think
the idea of having a number made up of
prime factors and adding one and all the
prime factors if you just add one to
each of those prime factors still
remains a factor of that number it's not
at all obvious to me that it should do
that and in fact it's clearly not that
common that it does it numberphile is a
collaboration with the mathematical
sciences Research Institute but it's
also made possible thanks to you the
viewers especially these people who
supported us on patreon our thanks to
them we could at least ask as we go
along in the sequence do we get a new
prime at each step